welcome to today's session on illicit
indicators and the contested politics of
numbers my name is Alex Cooley and it's
my pleasure along with my co-director
Jack Snyder to welcome you to the next
in our harriman core project series of
events on human rights in the
post-communist world actors strategies
and outcomes and the purpose behind the
series and we've seen some of you before
is to bring academics working on human
rights types of issues and especially
issues of measurement strategies and
effectiveness into dialogue with
policymakers and this is the final one
of our cluster of events here in
February we'll have some more events in
April and then again in the fall so
please stay tuned for those I am
delighted to introduce today's panel and
Peter andreas Sally Mary large metal
field and Elizabeth Egan let me just
briefly introduce all of them and then
they'll kick off today's discussion
Peter on dress is professor of political
science and international studies at
Brown University his work bridges the
fields of security studies and
international political economy this
includes research on transnational crime
and crime control the politics of
borders and smuggling in the political
economy of conflict post-conflict
reconstruction and he's conducted field
work in a great many different locales
including latin america united states
and the balkans undress is the author
co-author a co-editor of eight books
including titles like blue helmets and
black markets the business of survival
in the siege of Sarajevo policing the
globe criminalization Crime Control and
international relations and my personal
favorite title sex drugs and body counts
the politics of numbers and global crime
and conflict Cornell University Press
2010 co-edited with kelly green hill he
is currently researching writing a book
on the politics of smuggling in American
history tentatively entitled smuggler
nation eelus
trade and the making of America to
Peter's left Sally angle Mary is
professor of anthropology and law and
society at New York University her
recent books include colonizing Hawaii
the cultural power of law Princeton
University Press two thousand human
rights and gender violence translating
international law into local justice
university of chicago press 2006 gender
violence a cultural perspective
Blackwell's 2009 and the practice of
human rights tracking law between the
local and global co-edited with mark
good Dale Cambridge University Press
2007 she is past president the law and
society association in the Association
for political legal anthropology and
president-elect of the American
ethnological society the law and society
association awarded her the Hearst price
for colonizing Hawaii in 2002 in the
Calvin prize for overall scholar and
contributions to socio legal scholarship
in 2007 and the School of American
research awarded her the ji Staley prize
in 2010 for human rights and gender
violence I should also mention that
Professor Mary is involved in an NYU
projects on indicators as a technology
of global governance and we're also
pleased to welcome her colleague here
Kevin Davis who's part of that project
too so we're really delighted to have
you here today with us Laura nettle
field you may have seen her here before
she is a postdoc for the year here at
harriman author of the excellent book
hoarding democracy in bosnia-herzegovina
the hague tribunals impact in the
post-war state and co-author with sarah
wagner of the book also forthcoming from
Cambridge University Press schreber
neatza in the aftermath of genocide she
is also a contributor to the sex drugs
and body counts volume delighted to have
Laura here and finally our practitioner
and and we're very happy that oh I'm
very happy to introduce Elizabeth Egan
and and she's come here a little bit on
short notice and so we're we're really
grateful to you Elizabeth to bring your
perspective but she's really an ideal
practitioner to comment on these
presentations elizabeth is program
officer for the information program the
human rights and governance grants
programs and human rights data
initiative at Open Society Foundations
with the information program she focuses
globally on human rights data projects
the use of new media tools and
information management developing grants
and grant making for organizations
creating sets of data to answer human
rights and policy questions and support
advocacy campaigns with data
visualization tools and tactics she also
introduced the human rights data
initiative project with the goal giving
human rights organizations in the OSI
network the opportunity to think about
what kind of technology tools might
contribute best to their work Elizabeth
holds a BA from the University of
Michigan she has preview Minh Rights
Watch and 40 SI and Budapest thank you
to you all one final comment I'll make
here I've known Peter for a while and I
think was that maybe two or three
American political science association
meetings ago I he was telling me well
what's your next project peter he said
oh I'm co-editing a book on illicit
indicators and I just said what okay and
then I kind of moved on to the next
topic cuz I didn't really understand
what he meant by this apparently I
wasn't alone because my understanding is
quite a few University Press editor's
passed up on sex drugs and body counts
and everyone who i've spoken to since
really regret that decision the book has
sold out in three weeks it's gotten rave
review from slate it really is a
provocative work that that's been
initiating and stimulating all sorts of
debate so Peter hats off to you and
welcome to Colombia thank you very much
you want me to come up there whatever
you like whatever let's talk from here
if you get here just season like um you
know I was going to make a pitch for the
book but Alex already did it for me so
thank you Alex that was very generous in
fact I could not i'll just say i could
not even get my current book at her
interested in in this book at the time
but anyway it worked out I'm not
responsible for the title that's my
co-editor so I'll blame her a different
suggestion I actually like it but it's a
it's a little edgy little risque for
academic books anyway the book was
inspired in some ways by two brilliant
people one is Albert Einstein of course
not everything that counts can be
counted and not everything that can be
counted counts that's quite a brilliant
observation and then the other brilliant
person is Steve Colbert the statistics
you don't compile never lie that was
quite insightful as well it's right up
there with Einstein all right well we
discovered in putting this project
together is based on a couple
conferences one at the Kennedy School at
Harvard and when it at the Watson
student at Brown is that really there's
remarkably little out there in the
literature on the politics of
quantification there's a there's
actually a small and growing cottage
indices of books on sort of how
statistics lie and how does how to
measure better and and how not to get
deceived by numbers but actually looking
at the policy implications and tracing
how these numbers are created produced
abused and reproduced through the policy
process really it's a fairly thin
literature so this is just you know in
some ways the first take it's a very
interdisciplinary project with
anthropologists sociologists political
scientists and actually a few policy
practitioners involved so more broadly
speaking it is a book about the numbers
fetish in policy debates and the two
realms that were most interested in this
book is are the realms of global crime
and conflict now what these two things
have in common is that they're low
visibility in terms of ability to
actually count accurately but high
visibility in terms of politically
charged often symbolically charged
policy debates there's a particularly
problematic to say the least to do to
measure in these realms right
transnational crime and conflict however
the
and the insistence that we have some
numbers some data is is as present in
these issue areas as any other any any
other policy realm what I'm going to
mostly focus on in the in the few
minutes I have is on illicit flows of
various sorts especially in the case of
drugs we look at both the supply side
who supplies the numbers but also the
demand side wait you know where what is
the demand are the consumers of these
numbers if you will in this case we
focus especially on policy makers and
very much important the media you know
one way to look at this in terms of the
consumption of these numbers you can see
they're purposely gullible though I
think that's an oxymoron just say you're
purposely gullible but it's that's
characterized as some of what's going on
and that's because they serve a very
important function uses sometimes subtle
sometimes obvious so let me focus on you
know Kelly Nye co-edited the the
conclusion and the and the introduction
and conclusion then I wrote so the
second chapter which focuses on the on
the world of illicit flows here we talk
about people Goods and money which are
inherently difficult to measure right
there's no quarterly business reports
job growth statistics export numbers
import export balances and so on and in
fact the actors are actively trying to
evade being seen or counted right the
success of a smuggling operation after
all depends very much a not being
detected noticed quantified and so forth
nevertheless the preoccupation with
quantification is as evident in the
illicit realm as it is in the licit
right so there's all these attempts to
both measure the size of illicit markets
aggregate data and at the same time the
effectiveness of state controls in
suppressing those activities what I
arguing in that particular chapter is
illicit pneus makes possible a politics
of numbers that is particularly
susceptible to manipulation distortion
and even outright fabrication because
you can't really falsify the numbers you
can't repeat what the researchers
presumably did and in fact these numbers
are remarkably unquestioned in policy
debates and media reporting now I don't
want to give you the impression that
what we're talking about here is it's
not just cynical manipulations by
producers and users of numbers but
rather a more nuanced argument that this
is a really these are coping strategies
in a media and policy environment that
absolutely demands numbers there's an
imperative if you will to quantify it
privileges bad data over no data promote
simple and visible metrics of policy
progress and effectiveness that are
ambiguous and misleading the very act of
counting it seems even if it's pseudo
counting makes invisible makes the
invisible world appear more visible and
they're more accessible and real in the
policy debate so let me just give you a
few examples of this um basically a
story here if it's not counted it does
not count I mean that quite literally
right so if you just look at the
official numbers thrown out there by
Interpol the estate department United
Nations and so on on various illicit
flows drugs sex trafficking wildlife
trade migrant smuggling and so on all
these numbers are inherently estimates
very rarely sometimes very rarely is
there any explanation of where the
numbers came from any qualifications
about how bad how much of these are
really just extraordinarily rough
estimates so let me give you one
particular example from the United
States the US State Department every
year publishes come something called the
International control strategy report
it's basically a report card every March
first on judging countries around the
world and ham
they are cooperating with us
anti-narcotics efforts and in that
report card they basically give a
country summary of how much they've
eradicated how much they've seized how
many people they've arrested and so on
it also gives estimates of the size of
drug cultivation in Peru and Bolivia
Colombia and so on notice there are some
things that are not even mentioned let
along the dubious data but some things
aren't even mentioned so for example
domestic marijuana cultivation the
United States is one of the largest drug
producers illicit drug producers in the
world with marijuana arguably one of
America's leading cash crops that we as
I would suggest we really don't know the
real numbers or take for example the
United Nations annual drug report
they've gotten better over the years but
in the early 1990s they put out the
number the world illicit drug trade is
worth 500 billion dollars right it's a
nice round big catchy actually scary
number right where did it come from
absolutely no explanation this number
proliferated it became the conventional
wisdom reported in media accounts and so
on so much so that you have a process
you could even call it some people about
numbers laundering in the sense you lose
track of where the number originally
came from well how big is the world drug
trade Oh 500 billion who said that I
don't know I think it may be some UN
report somewhere anyway it became
naturalized and perpetuated and recycled
and indeed laundered so you don't even
know necessarily the original source now
in subsequent years they reduced the
number okay so to 400 billion again a
nice round big number an economist who
was a consultant a Colombian economy
Francisco to me was a consultant within
the UN agency coming up with this number
he was skeptical after all he wasn't a
career worker
the UN at the UN drug office he was just
a consultant on this stuff he actually
dug around sand where did you come up
with this number and the best answer
that they could give him was well the
real number whatever that means is 365
billion but we rounded it up to four
hundred billion dollars so anyway as he
put it if it was if it was 340 would
have they rounded down to 300 billion so
anyway there is a political imperative
if you will to inflate some of these
numbers the UN basically like any agency
very much wants media reporting
attention and so on and that frankly is
no press conference unless you have a
number because the world drug trade in
some ways doesn't exist unless you
actually designate a number to it it
almost doesn't matter what the number is
as long as it's big and scary and
eye-catching which these numbers
certainly were we don't we step back
nationally again the State Department
look at the u.s. statistics on global
sex trafficking the common number used
by the by the US State Department is 600
to 800 thousand trafficked per year now
this number again much media reporting
New York Times and PR and so forth
became the standard number the GAO
actually did a report which questioned
that number said look the methodology is
really squishy we have no idea if this
is true the GAO report did not get
picked up in media accounts and so on
now some facts are not just inflated but
they turn out to be pure fiction so for
example the New York Times picked up on
a number of the child internet porn
business and this number was also used
in a congressional hearing the number is
20 billion dollars a year
now where did this number originally
come from well a congressional staffer
they used it for the hearing said well
it came from this NGO an anti child porn
in geo and you go to them and they say
where'd you get it well we got it from
this other NGO so you go to that other
NGO and ask where did you get oh we got
it from mckinsey business consulting
firm okay you go to Mackenzie so where
do McKinsey get it another NGO you go to
that NGO where did they get it the FBI
you go to the FBI we never would use
that number we've never heard of that
number you can't find in any FBI
document right um now here's a huge
problem which is sometimes it's obvious
that the numbers are squishy problematic
and so on but a common response when
when you push the people who produce the
numbers is I can't tell you it's
classified it's behind a veil of
intelligence it's sort of like trust me
I know it we're doing and if I told you
what we're doing well I'd have to kill
you because it's you know it's it's in
the intelligence world so that by
definition creates a problem act for you
know academic research in terms of
repeating or any transparency if you
will in in methodology so I hope you're
a little bit convinced that there's some
problems with these numbers now the
question is you know what purpose do
they serve by producing these numbers
and as I've alluded to there's an
imperative you need a number any number
but again preferably big and scary to
become part of the debate otherwise
you're just not part of the debate
numbers it's not just the policy debate
but the broader public debate so they
actually help it's not just numbers that
matter but numbers help give credibility
to a larger story a narrative if you
will in this case a narrative of global
crime booming proliferating an
unprecedented threat ah
and we're not doing enough about it now
maybe all those things are true I
certainly we certainly don't want in
this book to basically say that these
are not serious very serious problems
but we want to point out that there is a
kind of dominant narrative about the
illicit side of globalization of you
will as entirely new and different and
let me throw some numbers at you to show
you how new and different it is and
these numbers come from precisely the
same sources that I disc wote it they
tend to be regurgitated rather than
question there's actually a small
industry of a cottage industry of kind
of popular books in this vein ah that
have come out in the last decade and a
half probably the best of them are the
best written the best one known is by
Moises nyeem the editor for matter of
foreign policy magazine called illicit
as a long subtitle is it's uh basically
he says in the preface or right up front
in the book look these numbers come from
the most reputable legitimate sources
around the world says that and then he
uses them throughout the book as
evidence that this is an unprecedented
global threat he would not when others I
don't mean to just pick on Moises name
he and others would simply not be able
to write their books without those
numbers so they have an incentive
obviously not to question them too much
there's even books with the very title
of the books is a quantification
dependent so you know a book on I use it
sometimes for teaching on piracy
intellectual piracy and and and and a
knock-offs it basically said you know
inside the world's you know fastest
growing industry so that's a
quantification claim right there's other
books that you know the second the
world's second largest illicit trade
interesting in this realm of advocacy
about illicit trade issues there's
actually a kind of competition everyone
recognizes that drugs are number one no
debate about that it's a question of how
big the drug trade is everyone agrees
and concedes drugs as number one however
there's this jockeying for position
depending on what you're advocating were
number two so the people are concerned
about art and antiquities we're number
two the illicit arms trade we're number
two sex trafficking we're number two
migrants monthly we're number two on and
on and on and on you can find in
different places claims about being
number two behind just behind drugs and
so on now the numbers as I point out
what however credible they are actually
give credibility the sort of master
narrative about the globalization of
crime now i have only like one minute
left i meant to say a lot more about the
other side of this which is measuring
policy effectiveness if you think it's
hard to measure the activity what's
obviously equally difficult to measure
how well agencies are doing their job
and suppressing those activities so
understandably again it's not a cynical
argument coping strategies you have
officials DEA Homeland Security whatnot
you know going before Congress every
year justifying their budget saying and
what do they do they point to arrest
numbers eradication numbers seizure
numbers how many organizations they've
disrupted and so on if you actually
unpack all those numbers even the ones
that that might be hard so for example
how many hectars you eradicated of coca
that's a hard number right it's not
fuzzy but it doesn't actually tell you
how much new planting there was that
year right they often saying we have
record eradication this year well there
could be a lot new planting or similarly
record number of arrests of drug lords
or Street dealers they don't tell you
how much replacement there is of lower
level people quickly going into those
and that actually explains much
not all but much of the violence in
Mexico today is if they take down major
drug trafficking leaders they're
replaced has created a competitive
dynamic between drug trafficking
organizations disrupting them leading to
dramatically higher levels of violence
in the QA and since I've run out of time
we can go into a lot more about this so
for example border seizure numbers
if seizures go up dramatically customs
that Homeland Security gets applauded
but if seizures go up dramatically
frankly it also might mean there's a lot
more drugs coming across the border
because all things be equal you're going
to seize more if there's more drugs so
there's this weird symbiosis between
increased drug trafficking and showing
that you're doing a good job if suddenly
you were weren't seizing and the drug
trade disappeared at least in the short
term it would look pretty pretty awkward
I'll stop there thank you I just want to
begin by saying this is a wonderful book
I hope you have a chance to look at it
it is very persuasive about how crazy
these numbers are sort of noticed this
looking at the US State Department
report on trafficking for 2010 which
announces that there are twelve point
three million traffic victims in the
world and they have identified forty
9360 too much for about the exact number
so one wonders where they have got from
49,000 to 12.3 million but it doesn't
seem to be explained but it does really
raise for us the question about how
numbers matter what the effects of these
numbers are and how they are intervi
intersect with politics I've been
working on the question of how
indicators are produced and how they're
used for a couple years now and some of
this work has been done with Kevin Davis
and Benedict kingsbury at the nyu law
school and I can't help beginning by
giving you a little story because I've
spent the last couple of days at the UN
statistical Commission meetings as part
of my research on how violence against
women is measured and at these meetings
this is a UN commission that consists of
representatives from national
statistical offices from all around the
world and they sit and debate things
like the principles of Statistics there
is a culture of statisticians out there
I've discovered and just as I left today
a major battle was brewing just to show
that these things matter between several
countries and the UNDP that you
development program for its Human
Development Index which it apparently
has recently revised in ways that make
some countries look worse and they don't
like that they have a new poverty index
and they're also our big fights about
whether or not the national data matches
the International data so here we get
sort of north-south politics happening
one of the problems is that the
international data may measure things
differently than the national data so
for example the life expectancy in South
Africa by the international figures is
47 and by the national figures is 57
well that's pretty significant and these
numbers all get folded into the
Millennium Development Goals and other
kinds of indicators of economic
development growth so South Africa cares
a lot so south africa morocco and brazil
have all accused the UNDP of changing
these numbers not paying attention to
the official statistics I've tried to
figure out what official statistics are
and those turn out to be things that
countries produce so if UN agencies
produce and they're not official will
the UNDP guy said they are official
apparently the worst offense is that
some of the data that the UNDP used for
the new human development index was
produced by some scholars in one of
those academic institutions to the north
with a lot of red brick around so there
was some Harvard guys who did a study of
educational levels estimating mean
number of years in school using all
kinds of data but this was not official
data so they're going to try to roast
the UNDP for this now why does this
matter why are they fighting about this
clearly there are implications for
national reputations for funding for all
sorts of things that make it worth
having this battle which is now
described as getting removing the
disparities between national and
international data as if this is just a
matter of kind of conversation
negotiation and avoids the fact that
mall these things are measuring the
unknowable you know mean number of
expected years in school you have to
assume that nothing changes that people
stay in school the same way they used to
your populations are fixed I mean these
are all very difficult so when I was
talking to the UNDP if
about this problem on how he's going to
deal with it he said well this is our
politics I don't do politics i'm just a
statistician which i thought that's an
interesting no position to take that we
do statistics we don't do politics which
is sort of a way that we tend to think
about statistics and one of the things
that's great about this book and about
the kinds of things that we're finding
out as we look at the various different
indicators it is all about politics but
the question is how does the politics
and the technical piece merge because
it's also about technical skills and
expertise and who has expertise and what
kind of expertise and how do those
things go together so those are very
complicated questions and I am now in my
early stages enough of an ethnography of
statisticians nothing I plan to do and
it seems that there's a possibility that
this is a community there's actually a
global statistical community turns out
which doesn't want to do politics so let
me begin with a couple comments on this
book then hope to encourage you all to
buy it and read it it certainly makes an
important contribution and highlighting
our current preoccupation with numbers
and the political nature of them the way
they're manipulated it sort of begins by
saying a lot of the previous work has
been done on how bad numbers are errors
and statistics consumers who are duped
by statistics identifying the danger
signs or consumers to pay attention to
sort of how to lie with statistics so
this genre of work has been around for a
while but this book is doing something
different it's making three moves that I
think are all very significant first of
all it's turning to the international
sphere and certainly in the work that
I've been doing the last couple of years
what's really stunning is the way the
preoccupation with statistics and
measurement and quantification has just
taken off in the international world
endless comparisons of countries about
all kinds of things that they do
increasingly important in the management
of global affairs there are endless
rankings of countries
since the mid-90s new demands for
numbers all the time I've been studying
violence against women for a while and
since you know about 2000 the the
drumbeat is we need more numbers about
how much violence against women there is
out there as if that's a noble thing so
more data available on the internet and
interested in measuring things that are
really very difficult to measure such as
the rule of law the Ease of Doing
Business I have a list here which I
can't seem to find so we've had a
fluorescence of these indicators that
compare and rank countries Oh rule of
law corruption governance failed States
human development measures of compliance
with global standards like human rights
corporate social responsibility has
indicators so this notion that if we
just had more measurement we could have
better monitoring and evaluation of what
organizations do is very fundamental to
the contemporary governance mode and
people have talked about this is an
audit culture new modes of management
lessons learned in which you generate
data and it folds back in
decision-making so we have some kind of
new governance strategies that are very
evidence-based governance premise on
gathering this information so this
demand for numbers is strong and growing
stronger and they provide us the sense
of certainty and clarity that people
talked about trust in numbers and that
was sort of what Peter said you get a
number like you know 430 6220 and you
figure oh this person must know and I
spent some time pondering why this
desire for more statistics more numbers
and I have found myself attracted to
ideas like desire and seduction I mean
we live in this incredibly complicated
unknowable world where we have to make
decisions and we have to act and
wouldn't it be nice if we actually could
rank every country in the world in terms
of human development in some kind of
accurate predictable way and I think
that's part of why we keep turning to
wanting more numbers as a way of
answering these questions
in the domain of realm of true
confessions I must say that when I sit
on an admissions committee and look at
graduate student applications I find
myself despite lots of skepticism about
gres looking at those GRE scores and I
know they don't mean anything there is
no necessary correlation between Jerri
scores and how well a student does who
knows what they measure right so I'm
full of skepticism but they're so easy
and there they are and they're so
comparable and so you know you sort of
end up looking at them anyway and I bet
I'm not the only one so we have this
notion of desire so the second important
move of this book i'm going to run out
of time before even get to my data is to
ask about the effects of these numbers
which they do a lot of interesting talk
mostly about how numbers create issues
and i know laura is going to talk about
this as well but numbers also are about
monitoring and accountability this new
form of governance so they're both about
doing the form creating issues and about
establishing control the rise and
interest in numbers really happen during
the 19th century with the growth of the
modern nation-state not surprisingly the
Prussians were apparently way ahead of
everybody else and doing statistics but
just collecting information was basic in
starting the early 19th century actually
so that we see a long term notion of the
state having to gather knowledge about
its population and we now are seeing
this moving into the global domain so
the third move this book makes is
challenging the question of the problem
counting the uncountable so we know
these are uncountable phenomenon that
they're looking at and I actually
believe that the rule of law and
violence against women and corruption
are also uncountable but what does it
mean that we are providing numbers we've
counted these things and I think that's
a really important question my student
for booty ramachandran who's here and
worked with me the summer studying the
way the US State Department trafficking
indicators are being used in India and
we spent some time talking to different
people about what exactly it means to be
trafficked and can you identify a woman
who is trafficked and we had a
conversation with a woman who graduated
from high school actually she didn't
graduate she left she went off to the
Gulf states from Calcutta she had made
some money is a sex worker she came back
home she found a friend she won't take
the friend with her is that trafficking
you know we know the trafficking is
often about people who move and then
maybe they can't get a job and they go
into sex work for a while and then they
go to other work so identifying the
thing right that trafficked person is
extremely difficult even at the ground
but nevertheless we are trying to do it
so they're clearly a lot of problematic
and political dimensions to the creation
of dissemination of numbers and we need
lots more skepticism and scrutiny but
what I might call a GRE factor here is
always going to stand against us now I
want to give you a brief overview of a
whole different problematic which is
that number creation is done over a long
period of time often I mean an indicator
creation maybe a I'm talking fast how
much probably five minutes to five I
want to take ALA Torian perspective
bruno latour talks about the creation of
scientific knowledge which is a process
that takes place over time in which
issues that are uncertain become settled
and then you can move on build on those
and you get more and more settlement of
ideas and then new questions and then
they become settled so for example how
to measure temperature we didn't know we
invented the thermometer we now figure
that the thermometer measures
temperature and we don't really worry
about whether that's true or not and you
see the same thing if you look at the
genealogies of indicator production
there are things that are debated and
contested and then after a while they
sort of become settled and accepted but
my argument is that there are multiple
ways that this settlement and acceptance
can take place and if you look at
different ones you can see they have
very different assumptions about what
the point is what you're measuring what
the institution who cares about it is
and what you're doing about it so I've
been studying how to measure violence
against women globally and that's what
my points about and I have figured out
so this is about this is part of the new
governance I'm going
fast because I'm not going to talk about
this and these are ways of collecting
data these are all very murky but it
seems to me that if we're looking at how
to measure violence against women there
are four different approaches which are
quite different in their philosophy
their goals the organization's behind
them one focus on gender equality one on
human rights 10 criminal justice and one
on national statistical capacity and
each one of these has assumptions about
what causes the problem how to fix it
how to get information which
institutions are going to support it
what kinds of expertise they value and
what constitutes improvement and so if
we look at the trajectory of development
of each of these over time you find
they're actually measuring something
quite different if you think about
violence against women for a moment this
is not a simple and straightforward
category it includes everything from
domestic violence to honor killing to
trafficking to various kinds of ritual
things to female genital cutting etc so
to be very brief this may be too quick
so the first model is one of gender
equality and this is an argument that
says if you're going to get gender
equality you have to diminish violence
or actually violence may produce gender
inequality this is kind of a feminist
approach so you want to get focusing on
measuring all sorts of kinds of
emotional and other kinds of behavior
that are making women feel subordinated
you are concerned with general social
tolerance towards gender violence and in
interviews have to be done a lot of
concern about ethical and safety
dimensions and this is being supported
by the Commission on the status of women
the Special Rapporteur on violence
against women and the secretary general
support and it usually relies on
sociologists and anthropologists so the
idea is you improve gender equality will
diminish violence a human rights
approach is quite similar also sees this
is a violation of fundamental freedoms
concern with how the states are failing
to act a lot of interest in getting
states to act more energetically on this
problem defined in a very broad way so
that looks at work and labor contexts
conflicts
very sexually so it's a very broad
basket of phenomenon is being supported
by the office of the High Commission of
human rights and the report of the
secretary-general and the experts you're
working on these indicators are largely
human rights lawyers they haven't
actually gotten to the point of counting
anything yet they're still working on
the conceptual side of the process
probably not surprising given their
disciplinary orientation that criminal
justice approach says this is a crime we
need to measure like we need to measure
other crimes use a Crime Victimization
survey approach maybe use categories
that match us crime trends like Homicide
assault battery rape some that are sort
of accepted within crime documents this
is supported by the UNODC the UN Office
of Drugs and Crime and efforts to do
international crime victimization
surveys and it is promoted by
criminologists and the idea is they
really want to know of the criminal
justice systems helping victims and the
assumption is that making better
criminal justice systems would improve
the situation of victims can you see how
we're going to get different measurement
approaches from these different ideas
now this is the UN statistical
Commission's approach and they're
actually primarily interested in
supporting national statistical offices
and the person who's behind this says he
doesn't really know anything about
gender or gender violence he doesn't
really care that's a problem for
sociologists he wants just to have good
guidelines for counting and this means a
relatively narrow survey the idea is to
develop guidelines and models and that
countries will do this for themselves
you train the national statistical
bureaus you have to get national buy-in
and you do it sort of along with me but
like a housing and demographic survey
the experts tend to be statisticians and
the argument is that better national
data will begin to produce some kind of
actions from the government's but it's
sort of not clear what government is
going to do it's just a matter of
producing better national data to make
governments accountable and if you can
get a government to do is measurements
over time then you can look at
improvement over time and
if you can get all that information that
I just whipped through and make sense to
I'm happy to that you did that let me
just conclude by saying as I was
thinking about these four approaches the
first two of which are quite broad and
the second two are fairly narrow in the
kind of behavior that they will count I
began to think about the resources
available to carry out surveys under
these various frameworks and at that
point it became clear to me that there's
a whole lot more money to do crime
surveys or national statistical surveys
then there is to do feminists gender
equality surveys or Human Rights surveys
so what this means is that of these four
options it's the second to that are
going to actually happen and now that I
realize that I can see that the
feminists are busy trying to persuade
the National Statistical people to put
their questions into their questionnaire
because in the end resources differ and
so the organizations that have more
resources and the more capacity to do
this kind of survey are going to be the
ones that end up deciding how the
phenomenon is defined how it is counted
how it is understood how it's theorized
and how the solution is imagined and I
think these kinds of policy implications
are really important for us to think
about but they're really embedded in the
whole trajectory of how measurement
processes take place so I'm sorry that
was so fast but I hope you could get
something out of it thanks so I'm
Elizabeth Egan I'm from the open society
foundations and I started this
initiative at the at Open Society
Foundations as a joint project between
two different programs specifically to
address what i think are some of the
underlying questions in the book
although I don't primarily deal with
statistics I deal a lot with this issue
of data I'll talk a little bit more
about the initiative in a bit because it
is sort of relevant but I think what
we're seeing here and what I saw as I
went through the book and what created
my my impulse to start the initiative
was sort of a deep shift in global
institutional arrangements arrangements
and information technology so we're
coming for the perspective that
information technology
then actually assist organizations and
particularly human rights organizations
to address some of the some of the
policy questions they encounter when
they're asked for numbers some of the
they're asked well how many victims of
domestic violence are there and you know
they really have to be able to make this
to do some manoeuvring to position their
their current access to what I would say
is a fire hose of available data coming
from multiple sources and really frame
that in the in the way that human rights
documentation and research has been done
all along there is a strong methodology
to human rights data collection and in
and in reality we really have to make
sure that when we talk about statistics
indicators numbers and metrics we are
really actually looking at them through
the framework of what a documented human
rice cumin rights case can actually do
prevent protect and preserve so I found
the book really interesting because I'm
not used to looking through my glasses
on I found the book really interesting
because it sort of confirmed for me that
both on the academic and policy side
we're seeing a lot of the same questions
that the human rights and governance and
and and policy actors on the NGO side
are really confronting which are their
concerns about numbers and metrics and
indices I think that it's it's given us
this these like three or four kind of
kind of questions or challenges that
we've seen in terms of what human rights
practice can do and so I wanted to I
wanted to just give you a little bit of
a little taste of what those might be in
terms of how they focus on technology
but also in how they do they deal with
data basically the first the first
challenge I would say is that the
investigatory tradition of human rights
work follows this methodology and we
need to be able to help that methodology
bring human rights data to a longer life
cycle information is now being requested
it can't just be the press release that
that admits that there's been a human
rights violation we have to talk a
little bit more about what does that
mean in the long run what does that mean
for the development policy what does
that mean for the information that we're
trying to gather to change the
governmental policy that's creating the
problem the
first place the second problem that I'm
seeing is that there's there's this sort
of shift recently in in the panoply of
partners that a government can choose to
create as I own identity that there's
performance metrics as well as these
sort of development monitoring bodies
that we talked about a little bit
earlier there's also this question about
how human rights organizations have
begun to advocate with non-traditional
targets it's not necessarily the human
rights committee or the UN or the
government directly there may be other
places that a human rights organization
might want to advocate the World Bank
for example is a new target it's about
recent target I would say the third is
this is this question of data when we
when we find that human rights
organizations are being questioned about
their accuracy that's been a long term
tactic for diminishing the success of a
human rights institution and it really
speaks to the to what Laura was saying
about about the way that the opposing
narrative which you always have to think
of when you develop your Human Rights
tactic can be used against you if you
make the slightest mistake and then the
final piece that I wanted to bring up
was this question about sort of the
globalized environment of of that they
work in terms of AG advocacy we've seen
over time that many human rights
organizations are concerned that the
domestic constituents aren't really
understanding what they're doing at an
international level and partly that may
be because they're confronting something
that they haven't quite quote-unquote
sold to the domestic narrative as
something that they need to work on and
so there's an opportunity as well for
new tools and tactics and new types of
data and drinking from this fire hose of
social and economic information to
really sell a human rights question as
part of the policy-making on the on the
ground so the human rights data
initiative was was created to kind of
address these threats and challenges and
there's three pieces that we sort of see
I was Lego blocks or I don't know and
start some toy metaphor it will help you
kind of they build off of each other
let's go with that the first is about
rebuilding information infrastructure
which is pretty simple and
straightforward the question there is
about how do we enable more powerful
ways for organ
physicians to preserve their data but
also how do we enable them to engage
with larger sets of data both numbers
and and other types of information the
second is about extending the use of
human rights information which means
developing data supported outputs to
enhance and extend narrative reporting
and then developing data outputs that
can be shared collaboratively so a human
rights organization cannot produce the
type of data that a statistical survey
may need but that data has to be remix
in such a way that it remains relevant
to this inevitable narrative that we see
of numbers and number demand for numbers
that we see and then the final piece
that we want to concentrate on is we're
really hoping that we can help human
rights and governance organizations
really extend their activity in a
direction they've been going for a while
which is to support them in
evidence-based policymaking initiatives
we see you know it's been described as
human rights organizations are teetering
on the fence of thinking about becoming
think tanks for example or they make an
attempt to do a statistical analysis i
think that there's a way in which in
which human rights organizations are
called upon because they understand the
rule of law they understand the they
understand a depth of political
narrative in a country and finding ways
to assist them to move forward with that
can actually complicate what has been
this straightforward narrative about how
many numbers can we throw on the table
and and use to base our policies off of
and then the final piece is that we do
get a lot of questions about whether
we're working on statistics and we're
really not the the the majority of our
work isn't really about statistics and i
think that there's a conflation between
data and statistics that many
policymakers as well as NGOs come across
and so that's a final piece of advocacy
which is shaping that shaping that
nuance and making sure that it's heard I
had a couple takeaways from the book
that I wanted to just throw out there
these are initial thoughts i'm going to
reread it but the first is that the
pressure to produce numbers is really
real and it's very real for ngos
themselves it's it's real in terms of
their their need to explain to their
donors what it
they do but it's also really it's also
really hard to say no when you're
invited to the table and if that
invitation is extended in the form of
please tell us how many how do we
measure and how do we say how many
victims there are of a certain crime
it's hard to let that go I think we
brought up before this question of
grabbing the attention of your advocacy
target or of even the press I think that
it's clear to me that organizations
really shouldn't be producing and
collecting statistics if they're not set
up for it and but I think what's really
exciting to me about the book i'll come
to the third one in a sec but what was
really exciting is that the the book
itself prescribes this litmus test about
how to say you know okay let's take a
step back at the number if I'm requested
to give a number if I'm looking at a
number let's let's stop and think about
what that is and if you hadn't read the
book I encourage you to pick it up and
check out the whole thing but also
specifically this question and to me
whenever I get a project or I talk to an
organization about their plans in terms
of evidence-based policymaking what we
always discuss is who's served by
collecting the number as opposed to how
do you frame your success in light of
service to your client base service to
the people that you're protecting and I
think that among among funders as well
as among policymakers we really need to
be able to step back and say that is the
true goal the true goal really is not
this number is large and therefore we
must pay attention which speaks to my
second point or my third point but
really what is the point of doing human
rights work if you're not actually
fulfilling a human rights issue if
you're not preventing or or alleviating
a human rights problem um and the final
piece here is that numbers really do
urge us to do something and so what we
really but I think we need to do is sort
of replace that generator with something
else so since I'm coming to this from a
from a human rights core funding aspect
my my idea here and my hope here is to
help organizations that
work with feel that they can push back
at the quantification of the human
rights movement the that is that's hard
to do it's hard back it's hard to sit
there and make sure that you continue to
complicate the narrative but that's
always been the human rights movements
goal we have to be able to think closely
and long and hard about what is it we're
trying to say with our with each human
rights case that we bring and so I think
that there's also this this other this
other interesting hazard in developing
societies where we're seeing that the
people across the table from the human
rights organization on the government
side are becoming more and more
technocratic and they are becoming the
kinds of people that can poke holes and
shoddy numbers and enjoy doing it very
much and so really being able to that
might want one piece about this this
generating of different urgencies is the
ability to stop back and say you know we
can't give you that number and this
number is not important because so I
wanted to give you a few of examples a
few examples to to really to really show
you what it is that we've been seeing as
the human rights and governance
organizational response to this pressure
for numbers we're seeing some
visualization we're seeing mashup of
data and we're seeing the something
that's really interesting to me which is
this this recognition that there are
silos of information within different
organizations and in coalition if there
is a neutral platform that lets people
submit information to it it's a little
more technical than that but but sharing
data repositories and really determining
what information is shareable with
respect to privacy with respect to
possibilities what we can do with that
information and then the last two pieces
are about sort of regrouping and
refocusing the storyline a little bit
more so this is an example of a
visualization from Human Rights Watch
that was that's from about eight years
ago so on the
on the left-hand side you'll see a map
of downtown Tashkent this was a target
this was directed the European Bank for
Reconstruction and Development when they
had their annual meeting in Uzbekistan
and so on the right you have the number
you have currently more than 7,000
political prisoners are being held in
colonies on the basis of their religious
beliefs that's the number but on the
left you have a little bit more
complexity to this it's a tourist map of
downtown Tashkent that shows you the
proximity of human rights violations
sites to tourist sites that's a
different narrative maybe that's a
generator of a different kind of
conversation in the policy sphere this
is a really recent one which is I'm
calling the long tail of evidence pre
tweet know if I can get away with that
title the basically i noticed this
really during the last couple of weeks
where I saw that Peter Boogaard who's
the emergency retailer show's director
for Human Rights Watch confirmed that
there were undercover police loyal to
the Egyptian president committing act of
violence and looting and he did this by
going to the hospital talking to the
hospital staff and finding out that they
had found identity cards on some of the
people who were coming into the hospital
to be treated and it turned out they
were carrying police identify
identification cards and had sort of
been caught I guess in the crossfire and
to me this really strikes this really
shows me something really interesting
which is about sort of the long tail of
information gathering and relationship
building that human rights organizations
do before they put forward a quick and
pithy remark and without that
reputational standard behind what
they're saying it doesn't matter how
many times it was tweeted it has to be
real so this was victory for the sort of
the the footwork of human rights work
and then here's some footwork class
technology which is the it's a map of
village damage in in south ossetia and
it was this was when Human Rights Watch
had access to some of the the UN
satellite and other independent science
scientific satellite pictures of this
area and they
through and they analyze what had been
burned and what had been not burned and
what was razed to the ground and making
the decision to call it razed to the
ground or not but it wasn't until they
had the on-the-ground presence to match
that time data and match the their
knowledge of what was going on that they
were able actually to make a statement
about this information you can't really
do anything with this and say except to
say on this day there were pieces that
were destroyed without that sort of
check of of the the information
specialists in a human rights world so
I'm going to end a little bit a little
bit on a trick I think one of the things
that we've seen is that much of the book
is checking in on major indices and
institutions and numbers like drugs and
trafficking and death and there's no
doubt that NGOs have something to say
about those issues but my my what's
interesting to me about this whole
question of statistical debate and
indices and information is that human
rights organizations themselves have
identified their major gripe with the
current situation and that is that every
time we have to talk about confronting
and producing indices it's not clear why
countries must be comparable at a number
level rather than to an international
human rights standard it's it's not
clear why we should be conflating
countries into a pile of magical ranking
intercalate indicator climbing which is
also mentioned in the book is kind of
the least of the of the problems you
know it's easy to toggle one switch and
change your low and climb up the ease of
doing business ranking but from the NGO
perspective I think we have to even push
it a little bit farther every new index
only creates one more shadow report or
one more Indian NGO input mechanism or
one more lever that needs to be pressed
upon by those NGOs and not to respond is
a very difficult thing so the more that
we seek to create
cater the more that we seek to create
new mechanisms we also have to be
mindful of our sources of information
and the pressures that are on them so I
did a bad grad school thing and I pulled
out one quote from the book and I'm I'm
I'm wondering if anybody saw this as a
call to action the majority of traffic
statistics are developed by NGOs and
agencies there overextended and they are
troubled by this they're not ready to do
it at the same time that they're also
being diverted from their primary tasks
and I actually my answer to this would
be no I don't think that that this is a
call to action because this would be a
call to me this would say well maybe if
you fund them if you give more support
to their capacity to collect and
maintain and produce better statistics
then you would be doing something for
the greater good I don't think that they
would want it I don't think that they
that it would have the kind of results
that we hope from the human rights
movement and I actually don't think that
anybody writing in the book would say
that that was a good thing that
diverting Human Rights attention towards
producing better statistics simply to
fulfill the demand for numbers would be
the right thing to do so I'm going to
end there I think we'll have a bunch of
questions and thanks Elizabeth thank you
very much indeed for that okay so let's
move on to the question and discussion
part of the evening so if you have a
question ask you to step up to the
microphone here and please state your
name institutional affiliation and
please note that you are being recorded
for the record so honey a couple of kind
of pushback questions I saw how much
money what's your name I'm an assistant
professor in the political science
department sorry I forgot the rules
already um
this this kind of goes directly to the
sum of the last things that Elizabeth
was just saying but is the problem here
really numbers or or bad numbers and I
heard a lot of criticism of numbers but
and but are there any good numbers out
there and if there are Wow would we know
right because if it's if it's all just a
bunch of noise how would we really know
a good number when we when we saw it you
know and I know for academics you know
with with with Professor Mary's comments
what's problematic for politicians is
actually usually really good for
academics we actually look for measures
that show us different things in order
to really refine our theories and figure
out what's going on so there's a you
know a cross purpose there and also if
the numbers are problematic are they
more problematic than what came before
in other words if this is a new
phenomenon what was there before and if
what was there before were a lot of
disconnected anecdotes that we didn't
know how to knit together or we couldn't
tell how representative they were you
know isn't that also problematic and
then one final really directed a
question to Lauren nettle field it was
part of the of the story with with sure
Bernita and the skepticism about sorry
was some as part of the story about
schreber neatza and the fact that you
with more you reported numbers the more
pushback he found was that rooted in
skepticism about the numbers themselves
in other words did people not believe
them or thought that the numbers were
politicized you know so in a sense
actually exercising maybe not more
critical facilities the way we were
talking about but at least using the
numbers also as a point of pushing back
against
assignment of blame great Thank You
Connie thank you for that rich set of
questions I'll ask the panelists to
respond in order and perhaps also engage
some points from the other panelists by
way of response to so Peter great
questions I'm afraid and probably won't
answer all of them but I was
particularly struck by your question are
all numbers bad are there good numbers
and I guess my reaction that was I hope
I didn't give the impression that
numbers are inherently bad the idea here
in this book is that we it's just a
beast more educated skeptical consumers
of numbers rather than dupes that we
need more you know numeracy that's a
word and that numbers are neither good
or bad they are constructs they don't
exist on their own and so for example
and you and this is related to your
question of you know are some numbers
harder than others so take the case of
drugs some numbers actually are quite
useful and quite hard and easily
measurable so for example in the drug
trade drug seizure statistics don't tell
us a whole lot in my view but price and
purity statistics on the street level
tell you a lot so you can you can look
cities across America and look at you
know price of cocaine how it fluctuates
the whole idea of the war on drugs is to
is to basically increase prices and so
they have undercover bus controlled
sales where they then basically
undercover purchases to basically trace
over time sales and you can track it
across different drugs marijuana cocaine
and basically by those numbers you
really see the very limited effect of a
of drug enforcement in terms of actually
being able to significantly raise drug
prices because in general it hasn't
happened except to some degree in the
case of marijuana you almost have
marijuana protectionism it's the easiest
drug to interdict from abroad and helps
domestic marijuana producers frankly
what came before interestingly enough I
mean this is part of modernization I
suppose most of the topics were covering
in here I mean obviously we've had
refugee flows and mass atrocities for
sent many centuries but what matters
here is is basically public awareness
beyond actually physical presence in
those places right so it's partly you
know the craze someone here who spoke
right after me it's actually the very
creation of a modern state in terms of
statistics sort of it's actually the
word statistics it's supposed to be
statistics in the function of the state
and also the media playing the role of
proliferating those numbers so that
people far away from these activities
with sex trafficking or genocide or so
forth are aware of them so before these
numbers for people not intimately
involved in the activities themselves
there was nothing I agree these are
interesting questions and I think in a
way I'm sorry Sally can speak in the mic
sorry slightly differently than just
about generating numbers because I'm
interested in the kind of second-tier
process which is you take the numbers
and you construct them into some sorts
of measurement device is the indicator
the so it's not just the raw number but
the ranking the series system and what
that process looks like I began looking
at these with a lot of skepticism this
kind of knowledge is very different from
the sorts of qualitative narrative
knowledge that I think provides the
context and the framing that is much
better way of understanding things but i
have come to
see that this is all so fundamental to
reform movements and so if I can be an
anthropologist for a moment it's kind of
like witchcraft or supernatural forces
which can be used for good or for evil
depending on how you they get used I
think it's important to recognize that
some things are much more measurable
than others so you could count things
like the number of people that show up
to this lecture probably fairly easily
whereas counting something like the rule
of law or who's trafficked is much more
difficult and I think one of the things
we're seeing is a movement of a
mechanism of knowledge production that
may work in some domains much more
readily than others and it's moving into
other domains where it's actually more
and more difficult but it's absolutely
fundamental to reform movements the
Human Rights documentation process is
just one example I've have watched NGOs
try to build issues and the first thing
they do is to count right to build your
issue you have to show how big it is how
important it is so I you know the
numbers are affecting us in all sorts of
ways is really a way that the
decision-making works so the last
question is what did we do before and it
may be that we had small cadres of
elites making their own private
decisions and one of the arguments for
these use of indicators and numbers is
that increases Democratic openness makes
things open to scrutiny produces
knowledge that publix can use and I mean
that can happen as well in certain
circumstances I think it's a matter
whose but you still have to wonder who's
measuring what how they defining it and
what kind of knowledge is being produced
but there is always this possibility of
greater public scrutiny when things are
known through this mechanism I think
that the problem is kind of both sorry
bad numbers and numbers themselves you
know I think I said in my presentation
pretty repetitively that I want the
conversation to move away from numbers
but I do i do think that when we talk
about patterns over time an organization
can really think about those patterns
over
if they have the opportunity say for
example there logbooks of intakes of
clients get scanned and scraped and they
can deal with it and that they could
make statements about the data that they
have and I think that that may be
helpful to them it's kind of a larger
and more expensive project than their
core task but it could be helpful that
I'm going to really you know if for
example the the government is saying
we're providing legal aid for these
problems because we think they're the
worst if the organization can look and
say you know we've been providing legal
aid for these and this is what most
people walk into our office for and you
should really take a look at those so
rather than numbers i think i think a
cumulative volume of activity over time
can make can strengthen an
organization's argument okay great let's
take some more questions so i'm kevin
davis from nyu law just wanted to follow
up on this question about the good
numbers actually i was curious if there
are other good processes for creating
numbers that you that you've found I
mean Elizabeth you mentioned that when
there's resistance from the other side
so to speak that I take it has prompted
some NGOs to do a better job of
collecting the numbers and transparency
obviously seems to well not obviously
but also might be a factor but as
wondering if there are other patterns
that you've seen in terms of what in
what sort of circumstances lead to
production of better numbers over time
whether it might be competition amongst
NGOs I don't know if that has an effect
but it would be worth thinking about or
mechanisms for participation in the
production of numbers or at least the
correct the correction where you allow
for people who are observed who are
using the data to sort of chime in with
Corrections you know the World Bank does
that sometimes what they're doing
business data to some extent or even if
just the involvement of public actors to
any extent seems to make a difference so
any thoughts you might have on the
patterns that and the processes that
seem to lead to the production of better
numbers over time would be interesting
and actually it was but just to the
extent that you can
just a comment so in the context that
I'm interested in we do sometimes need
to rank countries or at least to be able
to compare across countries you know
we've got a finite amount of resources
that have to be allocated across
countries and you have to set priorities
so and i would think that in some of the
human rights contexts you need to do
that as well you know set priorities
across countries at least some
organizations have to do that including
maybe the open society so i was just
wondering if you use numbers rankings so
or something for for that purpose in
your own work right growth let's take a
couple more and bundle them into
responses yeah Louise hi at least
Juliana Barnard College political
science department I have a question for
Sally Mary or anyone really since you
talked about the possible beneficial
uses of rankings but we haven't heard
too much specifically about that tonight
earlier in the semester when someone was
here from Freedom House she spoke about
how sometimes representatives from
different countries call her on the
phone to lobby for higher boosting the
rankings so I just wondered if you could
you know tell us or maybe Elizabeth tell
us some examples of cases where rankings
or internationally produced or codified
numbers or rankings inspire or motivate
actors to better themselves or just to
perhaps try to achieve a fit into a
category that may inspire a greater
charge transparency Freedom House about
rankings of level of democracy great
those with it and Jack you want to give
one and then we'll come back for the
next round yet Jack Schneider from
political science at Columbia
so whether we need numbers as opposed to
stories should depend in part on what we
want to do with the numbers what we need
them for do we need numbers for just
description of the phenomenon do we need
numbers in order to establish what
causes the phenomenon and what the
antidotes are to it and so just to know
in a rough sense what is happening a
bunch of good narratives can probably
tell you a lot about what is happening
oh you need numbers to know you know
exactly how much of it is happening but
it raises the question of well why do
you need to know that if you if you know
that the order of magnitude is something
like between 5,000 and 15,000 people
were massacred in rubber nitze for what
purpose do you need a more precise
number you may need numbers to know what
whether what you're describing is
representative but a lot of well-chosen
narratives can give you a sense of
what's representative as well as for
causes well the best way to do causal
inference is to combine narrative
descriptions of the causal mechanism in
detail with a statistical analysis of
you know frequency and correlation but
you can tell a lot about causation just
by tracing causal process and looking at
the
mechanism you can learn a lot about
causation just by finding out the
motives of the actors you know why they
said they were doing what they were
doing and get inside their brain to
think of how you're going to give them
incentives not to do it as far as
antidotes are concerned to try to decide
whether an intervention that an NGO or
whoever might want to take to deal with
the problem is going to work or not you
might need you might want to have good
statistics to evaluate effectiveness but
you could also do a field experiment
where you know you you've set up your
intervention on an experimental
population and you can you know test it
test it that way so I moreover in terms
of it having an impact on like the
climate of opinion sometimes it's a
single smoking gun incident that has
more impact than the numbers because
everybody knows that the numbers are
contested but the video of the Serbs
that was circulated that actually showed
them literally with the smoking gun had
more impact on served public opinion
realizing oh we really did do that and
it was terrible then all the numbers
debate did so I'm in favor of numbers
but I think that it's important to think
about well why do you need the numbers
rather than just to play this political
football game with them and can
narratives provide
nearly the same kind of descriptive and
causal inference value that the numbers
can great thank you so three very
interesting interventions here and i'm
going to give you all very unfair two
minutes each to respond to those so okay
very briefly question what produces
better numbers and i guess the the only
guiding rule i would say as a starting
point is that the counters should not
have a vested interest in the number
itself and in the case of the law
enforcement agencies that i look at in
terms of you know with Homeland Security
or customs or State Department's
trafficking persons office and so on you
know if they do that they're doing the
counting but then they actually now only
have a vested interest the number that's
come up but then the spin that they give
to their own numbers it's inherently a
problem there was a question about can
rankings actually stimulate improvement
I guess I'm a mixed view on that you
again take the trafficking persons State
Department report they rank countries
every year in three tier system and
countries around the world scramble to
make sure they're not in the third tier
because you're basically blacklisted so
at least all kinds of frenzy of behavior
to make sure you're not in that third
tier arguably that's a good thing in the
sense that you know Japan Israel so on
somebody cleared up their act to look
better does it are they fundamentally
changing their behavior it's much less
clear and then Jack's question about you
know narratives versus numbers and you
know why aren't sometimes narratives you
know more useful I guess you know it's a
longer conversation but in the cases we
looked at in this book and certainly in
in the chapter i did on illicit trade
what I found fascinating is that numbers
alone are good enough you need it you
need a narrative to hold the numbers
together so that the numbers a narrative
are not oppositional is kind of number
narratives versus number it's actually
you weave in those numbers in this
narrative that gives it life and then as
you pointed out yeah you can have images
to as a sort of added added thing but
the numbers on their own I think people
in any kind of numbers whether illicit
numbers or whatnot at some point your
eyes start to gloss over you know glazed
over and that's why you really need the
narrative effect Sally just to be brief
I was going to say that the State
Department trafficking indicators have I
gather had positive effect because some
of the critics have written articles
like Ian Gallagher no saying that it has
actually produced some passage of laws
in different countries I agree is
probably very iffy about whether there's
been substantive effect this is actually
an interesting question in the Human
Rights field because human rights has to
operate by various kinds of shaming and
naming and yet the field has been quite
reluctant to do ranking of indicators
and I've been studying a project by the
office of the High Commission of human
rights to come up with indicators but
they are very resistant to being ranking
they presented this idea to the human
rights committee that monitors the iccpr
and they got substantial push back
saying we don't want countries ranked so
that suggests that it might be powerful
actually to rank countries by human
rights but it may also be too
politically difficult but it is an area
that it might it might happen I think
the human rights community has a self
resisted this i would say that numbers
do produce theory but as I tried to show
in my brief talk the choice of numbers
is in fact derived from theory so your
theory shapes the way you pick numbers
and what you choose to measure so it's
not like there's a you know as I'm sure
you know a space where you could do the
numbers then build theory I think for
social movements you clearly need both
numbers and stories and that the image
of some child and the tenement was very
important and getting tenements cleaned
up and we see this all the time but I
guess my last point I think is that I
think is important to differentiate the
use of numbers and quantification for
research and for governance and I've
really been looking at this in the
governance area I think from research it
clearly is different these are not
actually distinct domains
made this distinction because academic
research can fold into a lot of
governance policy stuff academic
research turn serves to legitimate
policy numbers some policy numbers that
don't have academic background have less
credibility so they overlap but I think
in their intention at least they can be
separated and you know I could go on
about how you need qualitative data to
interpret the meaning of quantitative
information but i'm sure you all know
that why for example in a study and
looked at do fifty percent of the women
in mozambique who've been battered go to
helping systems and in another country
an industrialized country i think it was
about ten percent you know you look at
these figures you say i need more than
statistics to make sense of this thing
that looks sort of counterintuitive yeah
listen i want to sort of wrap all the
questions into a big pile and i think
that there's two pieces of discussions
that we have going on right now one is
about disbursement of resources and what
what how do you choose to disperse
resources and i think that that's an
underlying question for why why
indicators exist at all or why we
collect these types of statistics or why
we measure numbers and fight over how
big they are and then i think that
there's also this other question of
measurement and evaluation how do you
evaluate the success and you know it's
kind of a it's kind of a cheap shot but
i want to move back to this idea of what
is the human rights movement for the
human rights movement says that one
instance of torture is too much and so
we've counted one we should kind of be
done counting for a little bit while we
deal with the problem and we deal with
determining what it is that we can do do
we need to take a litigation case do we
need to see if there are other victims
that he knows do we need to uncover how
we're going to prosecute a case that's
largely taking place in unmeasurable
much like much of the book and
unmeasurable instances like sort of you
pull up a rock and you're seeing a lot
of different unmeasurable things I don't
really think that indicators in the end
are the only reason that funding or or
government or otherwise gets dispersed I
would be really surprised i think that
there's a complicated valuation
why we do what we do in terms of what
our government puts out with our own tax
money for example and it's much more
complicated than this game of indicators
in this game of ranking and then I just
want to go back to two more things one
of the projects I don't actually have a
body of conducted project projects to
really talk about my projects only a
year and half old so I think once we've
started making this a piece of what we
do we'll start to see some results a
year from now maybe but there's two
pieces that I'm excited about one is
this idea of creating a space within the
human rights organizations and
governance organizations who want to do
something outside of their their
traditional Human Rights monitoring
research to really experiment both with
new tools but also with whether they can
indeed engage in a research project that
produces a number and by carving that
out and making it something that doesn't
measure or evaluate whether they failed
I think that that's a really important
way to fund in this area and then the
other thing is that we recently put out
a call for proposals on challenging
commonly accepted facts in the public
policy sphere we opened it to think
tanks across Central and Eastern Europe
and the former Soviet Union and the
response has been overwhelming there are
indeed mass amounts of data that people
really think can challenge what is the
dominant narrative in their society and
they really think that with the help of
somebody to control and and filter that
fire hose of information they will be
able to make a big change so it's kind
of exciting and we'll see where they go
a year from now okay up very quickly
because we're almost out of time yes my
name is Jim dingman and I'm with
pacifica radio during the 80s and early
90s I would help Human Rights Watch
researchers in evaluating conflicts in
Central America and the Gulf War and one
of the problems is they're not
intelligence agencies they would like to
have gotten the data the first time I
ever saw them act on that kind of data
was at the end of the Gulf War when they
got the big data dump from the Kurdish
area but always the work of the
investigators that I worked with was
essentially they were lawyers building
up cases based on narratives they would
have loved to have statistical data but
they did couldn't get it because the
states weren't kind of give
the statistical data in order for them
to build their cases so that to me is
one of the problems and looking at this
because you can't get that kind of
information the state's not going to
give it up to you in order to do that
and I don't recall because the last time
I work with them we were trying to
figure out oh the sheer revolt after the
first Gulf War I spent six months in the
office trying to figure it out and we
could never get the data to statistical
data do it so right there is a problem
it's very difficult to overcome great
thank you and Kathy Kathy new pomnish a
Slavic department Barnard College
there's nothing more guaranteed to warm
the cockles of a humanities scholars
heart than to hear a lot of social
scientists question numbers and use
words like narrative and rhetoric thank
you jack I really appreciated that but
I'd like to push a little harder on the
negative possibilities of things that
are really harder to count and this is a
big question I realist at the end of the
evening um but but ironically Laura it
came up on your territory and when one
of your acquaintances who works at the
ICTY I'm sorry i added a letter they're
just ignored you know came and talked
about how they ended they worked on
indicators of success and it was
successful prosecutions which by that
quantitative figure um they're pretty
unsuccessful but we raised the issue
about what about the very existence of
the tribunal and what were the long-term
effects of its existence in the society
if someone comes out of the former
Soviet whether I've been no tribunals of
the sorts where there has been no
historical reckoning um but how do you
count that have you know and what do you
do what are the positive the negative
effects when you can't count something
we have to do something else thanks and
I'm going to ask one last one actually
directed to Peter and it's a long lines
what Kevin asked it seems to me there
are a number of different mechanisms
that indicators and rankings use to
affect political
change right one is that might serve as
a focal point for domestic civil society
to get you know angry and mad at the
government sort of take this up take the
case of the media another one might be
purely on playing on country's
reputation competitive sand jealousness
right one of the you know presentations
the lease was referring to careen car
Locker was talking about Armenia and
Azerbaijan and how they watch each
other's rankings like hawks and the
instant one of them goes down in a
ranking they come out with a news report
I mean that's a very distinct causal
mechanism right what seems to me
particular interesting about the illicit
indicators is that the mechanism is one
of attention getting right it's one that
what we're doing is a really big problem
and you know here's the inflated value
of the drug trade of human trafficking
you know that's one thing that's more
distinct about illicit indicators or
that stigmatization is a real mechanism
right so for instance State Department
it's not just the ranking it's the fact
that they're rated on this third tier
and yes you know you do not want to be
part of that third tier just as the way
you don't want to be on the OECD
blacklist as an uncooperative tax haven
is Jason Charmin has exposed or whatever
so I guess my question to you is then
what's distinct about these mechanisms
in the way in which these rankings and
ratings are used in the illicit sector
versus the listen sector maybe that
gives us some leverage on you know
Kevin's points to about you know
mechanisms of action here so I'll give
you all one last minute each to put all
these questions to rest and then we'll
we'll call it a night just very briefly
in the one perverse consequence of the
illicit indicator side of things is that
often policies are prioritized that will
generate the most visible and most
easily quantifiable results and you'll
downplay or under fund initiatives that
are maybe incredibly important but just
don't generate number so you know case
of Mexico or other
or Latin American countries with plugged
by plagued by drug violence in the drug
trade judicial reform in my view
absolutely the most important thing
that's needed in Mexico a lot of things
in Mexico right now but judicial reform
very hard to actually measure that
compared to how many traffickers they've
arrested how many you know hectars
they've they've Radek ated and how many
seeking of seizures they've done so that
has chronically been underfunded and
it's just an example of kind of a
perverse consequence of you just don't
put a lot of emphasis on things you
can't measure I would just say one more
thing about that it's also a reason why
preventive action in general in all in a
lot of realms including peacekeeping
whatnot you're not going to go into a
place to maintain them and have a lot of
political support to maintain the peace
because you you know typically you send
peacekeepers in reaction to something
but you can't quantify the value of say
preventive action say for example in in
Bosnia if the UN had sent large numbers
of peacekeepers anticipating the
conflict which they easily could have
been frankly it would be hard to you
know note the non event right the non
war how do you get credit in fact you
get a lot more credit for ending a war
than for actually preventing something
that you don't even know was going to
happen thanks basically I feel like
we've gotten a lot of really wise words
from people who know much more about
statistics and I do and so I just wanted
to end on a note from somebody from my
other world jaron lanier who wrote this
book you are not a gadget which I highly
recommend to anybody anxious about their
the world basically he says you know
information systems need to have
information in order to run but
information under represents reality and
I think that that is at the heart of
where I'm the majority of my concerns
are all right thank you so much thank
you to the audience your great questions
thank you to the panelists
you